[Musik]
Österreichs Kanzler Karl Nähe Hammer
fordert eine Mauer um Europa gegen die
illegale Migration Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach schockiert mit dieser Zahl
heute das Land 73% der Kinder- und
Jugendlichen sind noch immer durch
Corona psychisch belastet ja und mit der
Wirtschaft geht es weiter bergab es gibt
also viel zu besprechen heute bei 8:15
Uhr heute freue ich mich auf diese Gäste
zdf-legende Peter Hahne erstellt
Deutschland ein verheerendes Zeugnis aus
hier funktioniert bei gar nichts mehr
und das obwohl ja der Staat immer mehr
Schulden macht ja wie passt das zusammen
das erklärt uns der ehemalige ifo-Chef
Hans Werner sind auch Hendrik im Bruder
er warnt deutschland stehe vor dem
nächsten großen flüchtlingskollers viele
Jahre lang war er treuer Mitarbeiter von
exkanzlerin Angela Merkels die du
Politiker und Chef des
Wirtschaftsausschusses Michael große
Römer jetzt macht er der ampeldruck und
sagt wenn wir so weitermachen verspielt
Deutschland seine Zukunft er immer mehr
Menschen hätten Existenzängste
ihre eigene mieten explodierende
Nebenkosten müssen sich unsere
Abgeordneten hingegen keine Sorgen
machen schon jetzt haben die 736
Abgeordneten ja eigentlich ein nettes
Einkommen ab Juli wird es dann noch mal
ein bisschen mehr die Diäten steigen um
3,4 Prozent so stark wie übrigens seit
2015 nicht mehr konkret heißt das pro
Kopf 350 Euro mehr Macht im Summe dann
10.674 € Bundestagspräsidentin was
bekommt um die 700 € mehr Herr Herne
verstehen sie die Wut einiger Bürger
wenn man diese Zahlen hört die verstehe
ich voll und ganz
vor allem auch wenn es dann zusätzlich
noch um Europa geht die greifen ja noch
viel tiefer in die Kasse aber ich habe
bei der Bild am Sonntag mal vor zehn
Jahren eine Kolumne geschrieben als es
auch um das Thema ging und da habe ich
genau die Gegenposition vertreten und
gesagt
anständige Diäten für die Politiker dann
werden sie nicht korrupt dann brauchen
Sie keine Nebentätigkeiten und und und
man kann sie gar nicht gut genug
bezahlen und man kann die Geschichte
auch ganz einfach lösen wir halbieren
den Bundestag dann haben wir die Hälfte
der Kosten ich bin ohnehin der
Auffassung Politiker müssen gerade
stehen für das was sie machen und was
sie beschließen also jeder Politiker
müsste seine Kinder in Brennpunkt
Schulen schicken was meinen wir wie
schnell wir das
migrations-thema erledigt hätten
Politiker müssen jetzt ein Windrad
direkt vor ihre Wohnung gestellt kriegen
was meinen Sie wie schnell wir dieses
Problem gelöst hätten es ist eigentlich
ganz einfach und es dürfen nur noch in
den Bundestag Leute die einen
abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung haben
und dann haben wir so wenig
brauchen Sie gar kein Geld haben viele
Vorschläge oder jetzt gerade zusammen
machen könnte man macht ja ein bisschen
das gegen bei der Bundestag so groß wie
nie und jetzt gibt es noch mal Geld oben
drauf aber Herr Hanne sagt auch gute
Leute brauchen vielleicht dann auch
gutes Geld also können sie ihnen die
Erhöhung nein nein weil ich glaube nicht
dass mit mehr Arbeitsaufwand verbunden
ist es ist auch nicht mehr eine besseren
Qualität der Arbeit verbunden es ist
Status und es ist ein
Selbstbedienungsladen und im Übrigen
muss ich in einem Punkt widersprechen
Leute die gut bezahlt werden neigen auch
zu Korruption man kann nicht sagen dass
die Leute den Europaparlament Arbeiten
an der Hungergrenze dahin weggetieren
nein Geld macht verführerisch und
nicht Geld nach korrupt kein Geld macht
auch korrupt also es ist jedenfalls
immer ein Zug von Korruption da und
außerdem wissen Sie wenn Sie die Hälfte
der Abgeordneten weglassen werden sie
nicht die Hälfte der Ausgaben sparen es
gibt zum Beispiel sowas wie fixe Kosten
der Bundeswehr muss unterhalten werden
die bleiben und wie weit sind Spanien
ist eine Frage der Berechnung ich glaube
nicht dass sie Ersparnis groß werden
trotzdem gehört der Bundestag verkleidet
und man könnte manchmal damit anfangen
dass man den Neubau des Bundeskanzlers
Amtes und umwidmet und daraus ein
flüchtlingsquartier machen dann wäre es
endlich eine vernünftige Zweckbestimmung
wir sind gute Leute sollen auch gutes
Geld verdienen wie stehen Sie zu diesem
Thema finden Sie diese Diätenerhöhung
berechtigt
ich finde sie berechtigt weil die Diäten
schneiden ja nicht schneller als die
Gehälter im privaten Sektor sondern
genauso und wenn die um 4 % hochgehen
und wir haben 8 % Inflation dann heißt
das real gehen sie um 4 % runter also
worüber kriegt man sich hier auf die
Bürger keine
Inflationsausgleich sind
übereinander also ja nur gut von der
anderen Seite aber es ist ja die Frage
nach dem Zuwachs und der Zuwachs
stabilisiert den Status Quo nicht
sondern ist nicht genug um das zu
kompensieren ich meine man kann der
Meinung sein die verdienen überhaupt zu
viel Essen ganz anderes Thema ist die
Frage nach dieser Anpassung ehrlich die
Anpassung ist indexiert mit der normalen
Gehaltsentwicklung wirtschaftliche Sicht
25% der deutschen machen sich natürlich
aber auch sorgen dass sie ihre Miete
derzeit nicht mehr zahlen können und für
die ist natürlich so eine Erhöhung für
unverständlich
ja nun Sorgen macht man sich immer die
Mieten sind immer so hoch dass man sie
sich kaum leisten kann weil im
Wettbewerb untereinander man das Hoch
konkurriert aber
Mieter sind im Moment
tendenziell
nicht auf der Verliererseite dieser
Inflation sind den meisten sind die
Mieten nicht indexiert sondern einfach
nominal
definiert und die Gewerkschaften sorgen
dafür zu Recht dass die Löhne steigen
mit der Inflation und die Mieten steigen
nicht mit das heißt relativ neben die
Mieten dann auch ab also zu sagen dass
die Mieter jetzt in der heutigen Zeit
die besonders gelangweilten sein dieser
Inflation das ist auch inhaltlich falsch
aber als wäre reingrätschen die ähm
Leute empfinden das natürlich als
ungerecht weil sie ja im Endeffekt
erleben Sie ja dass derselbe Politiker
der sagt wir müssen den Gürtel enger
schneiden
so diese ganzen Nummern die gönnen sich
dann
diese Erhöhungen also ich möchte da
nicht ins Private gehen aber ich habe
das ganz klar als erster damals hat sie
noch keine getraut bei der Lindner
Hochzeit gesagt man kann sich nicht
morgens vor die Weltöffentlichkeit
stellen und zu sagen und das war konkret
so wir müssen jetzt den Gürtel enger
schneiden wir müssen sparen sparen
sparen und dann setzt man sich ins
Flugzeug mit
der ganzen Infrastruktur die ja Minister
haben
Flugzeuge und und Begleitfahrzeug ich
habe das alles erlebt ich war auch
können sie können den Leuten nicht doch
ich gönne ihnen was aber es muss
glaubwürdig sein es muss glaubwürdig
sein und das ist ein Vertrauensverlust
den wir gegenwärtig haben die wir haben
ja keine Politik Verdrossenheit wir
haben eine Politiker Verdrossenheit das
haben wir schon länger
jetzigen Regierung nein aber das gab es
ja immer schon diesen
Selbstbedienungsladen ja aber eskaliert
gerade fragen wir doch mal einen Nutzen
dieser Erhöhung sie sind sehr mit uns am
Tisch für sie gibt es ja ein bisschen
mehr geklappe 380 Euro oder ich bin ganz
dankbar dass sie das ausgerechnet haben
weil ich weiß das gar nicht weil das ist
ja eine Kopplung eine Kopplung an die
Löhne im übrigen auch in dem Fall wenn
die Löhne sinken dann sinken ja auch die
Diäten was im letzten Jahr der Fall war
und deswegen schadet vielleicht auch so
ein bisschen
sachliche Argumentation in diesem Fall
nicht der sogenannte
Selbstbedienungsladen den haben wir uns
nicht ausgedacht ich wäre froh wenn ich
eine Kommission einsetzen könnte die
sagt entscheidet ihr darüber wann
Abgeordnete irgendwie mehr Geld bekommen
oder nicht und ob das angemessen ist ja
das Bundesverfassungsgericht aber gesagt
das geht nicht das haben die
Abgeordneten gefährlich selbst zu
entscheiden und ich glaube die
Möglichkeit irgendwie Diäten zu erhöhen
dafür wird es nie einen richtigen
Zeitpunkt geben
ich verdiene jetzt mit diesen Diäten
genauso viel wie mein Landrat der
genauso wie ich für einen für diese für
diesen Bereich eines Landkreises mit
240.000 Menschen zuständig ist
auch da kann man fragen ist der Landrat
überbezahlt oder nicht ist kapriziert
sich dann häufig nur für
Bundestagsabgeordnete aber da ist es
eben genauso wie was ist angemessen und
da haben wir damals als Bundestag gesagt
wir setzen eine Kommission ein
ausgewerkschaftern aus
arbeitgebervertretern aus
Arbeitnehmervertretern Handwerkern aus
aus allen Bereichen der Gesellschaft und
die haben dann erarbeitet das ist
möglicherweise sinnvoll ist die die
eckenerhöhungen an die Lohnentwicklung
in Deutschland zu koppeln das heißt wenn
die Gesamtsituation so ist dass die
Menschen in Deutschland mehr Geld
bekommen dann bekommen Politiker auch
mehr Geld oder diejenigen die dann für
die Politik in Deutschland bundesweit
zuständig sind und wenn das umgekehrt
der Fall ist wird Ihnen die Diät auch
gekürzt ich finde das ist angesichts der
Tatsache dass man sowieso nie eine
zufriedenstellende Lösung erreichen wird
noch unter den schlechtesten die beste
ist ja auch das war auch eben gerade
Thema hier das ist nicht Gelenk daran
haben sie auch jahrelang gearbeitet im
Bundestag zu verschlanken woran
scheitert es denn da nun zunächst mal
ist das keine Entscheidung des
Bundestages gewesen sondern eine
Entscheidung ist des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes da gab es
eine Situation in Dresden bei einer
Nachwahl entstand das sogenannte
negative Stimmgewicht das heißt jemand
dürfte nicht zu viele Stimmen haben um
dann den Bundestag zu kommen absurde
Situation da hätte man natürlich sagen
können okay das ist eine Ausnahme bei
einem sonst Funktion gut funktionieren
im Wahlrecht das lassen wir jetzt mal
als Ausnahme so stehen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat das zum
Anlass genommen neu über die über das
Wahlrecht eine Entscheidung zu treffen
und da wurde dann entschieden wenn es
sogenannte Überhangmandate gibt
bisschen kompliziert also wenn man mehr
Wahlkreise gewinnt als der Partei nach
den Zweitstimmen zusteht dann kommt zu
Überhang wanderten und da hat das für
die anderen für die anderen nee also
erstmal für die Partei und die werden
dann ausgeglichen durch sogenannte
Ausgleichsmandate für die anderen
Parteien und dann erhöhte sich die
eigentlich zuvor das vergisst man auch
schnell vom Bundestag beschlossene
Reduzierung der Abgeordnete 598 und
jetzt haben wir über 700 und ist besteht
überhaupt gar keinen Zweifel daran dass
das zu groß ist und dass man das
reduzieren will und wie man das macht
über den Weg da wird jetzt trefflich
gestritten
Selbstbedienungsladen so energisch
zurückweisen es gibt zum Beispiel eine
Art von Parteien Finanzierung hier ist
bei anderen durchaus demokratischen
Ländern mit gleich längere demokratische
Geschichte nicht geben ich habe die
Zahlen nicht im Kopf weil sie sind
horrent viele Millionen die an die
Partei Stiftungen die Parteien
ausgeschüttet werden und da sind
abschiebestationen wissen sie besser als
ich das Leute die irgendwie als
Politiker gescheitert sind wie er man
Martin Schulz zu tun die finden immer
noch ein warmes Plätzchen in ihrer
petalstiftung nicht war in der
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung oder wie sie
gerade heißt schlimm dass da expolitiker
arbeiten oder finden Sie schlimm dass es
überhaupt Stiftung gibt die an der
Willensbildung sozusagen des Volkes ja
nur wirklich sinnvoll Mitarbeiter in
Frage stellen diese Stiftungen sind
versorgungsorgane tun sie jetzt nicht so
als wäre das in den erst jetzt in dem
Moment klar geworden wo ich gesagt habe
sie wissen es viel besser die sind alle
besetzt alle
wie mit Leuten die eine Kompensation
brauchen genauso das EU-Parlament eine
Weile sondern Abkühlbecken für Versager
waren einen Opa schicken nach Europa wir
können zusammen singen
die Stiftung der Parteien haben eine
wichtige Rolle bei der Entwicklungshilfe
die sind ja in allen Ländern vertreten
und bringen sich dort in die politische
Willensbildung ein
kooperieren dann auch im übrigen sehr
gut und mit den Botschaften das also
Teil der Auslandsvertretung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland was das
Personal betrifft ja das haben wir eine
überall dass da Leute irgendwo
abgeschlossen werden
nur gut wenn wir noch viele hätten die
so gut sind und da bin ich bei Ihnen
Herr wohler wenn sie sagen also mich
stört ist die Leute großen Teils im
Bundestag gar keine abgeschlossene
Ausbildung haben gesagt ich bin selber
ich würde das nein nein ich habe gesagt
geschlossene berufskraft wäre nein das
ist kein Studium
nein nur ein Schritt weiter
abgeschlossen
ja und wenn man fachkundige
Entscheidungen treffen will für das Volk
da muss man ja auch wissen worüber man
entscheidet ja man muss man kann sich
dann sortieren im Bundestag in die
entsprechenden Gremien sie sind in der
Wirtschaft andere sind im sozialen und
so weiter und wenigstens da muss ich
also eine berufliche Kompetenz
mitbringen wenn ich da entscheiden will
da geht's ja um viel und meistens hört
man und es wird nur irgendwas
vorbereitet und dann sitzt man da im
Parlament und Nick das ab ohne dass man
weiß worüber man überhaupt beschlossen
hat da sind ja Umfragen gewesen bei
Abgeordneten die aus dem Plenarsaal raus
kam worüber haben Sie den jetzt
beschlossen können Sie was erklären
haben wie Journalisten gefragt da
wussten
dafür holt man sich jetzt auch Experten
Robert habe beispielsweise 20 Millionen
jetzt ausgegeben um Rechtsexperten dran
zu holen ist das dann der richtig dass
man sagt
natürlich auch viele Rechtsexperten im
Ministerium
dazu braucht er dann extreme das ist
schon dann viel Geld ne also es gibt ja
auch den wissenschaftlichen Beirat
Bayern Habeck den kann er Fragen der
kostet gar nichts der arbeitet
ehrenamtlich da bin ich übrigens auch
dabei da gehe ich morgen hin ja aber da
haben wir doch eine
Selbstbedienungsladen das heißt es
werden jetzt in dieser Situation
ein paar Vorurteile zu haben
aber
Gleichstellungsbeauftragten jetzt müssen
sie doch strahlen wenn ich jetzt sage
dass gerade die ganze Zeit ja ich merke
ich dass die ähm in diesem einen Jahr
sind von ingo's und wer weiß was alles
Leute plötzlich ministerial
beamtenberater oder
ja das ist der Selbstbedienungsladen den
ich finde das ganz Scheiße
Selbstbedienungsladen klingt immer so
als müsste man da irgendwo in die Kasse
greifen ich gebe sofort
nicht aber lassen
Sie dass die Leute häufig gar nicht die
Ausbildung haben für das was uns oder
sie natürlich ein echtes Problem sie
stellen jetzt in den Ministerien an also
sowas hat doch nie gesehen also
sind die Vertreter der Partei Stiftungen
sind nicht Teil des Auswärtigen Dienstes
und diese Arbeit aber mit denen zusammen
das sind sehr witzige Situationen die
dabei entstehen ich habe mal all diese
Stiftungen in Washington besucht weil
ich weiß darüber machen wollte ein schon
sie dann war ich so an wie wieder dass
ich das Projekt aber fallen lassen
dieser Stiftungen für ein absolutes
eigentlich leben und die z.B in Amerika
die werden dazu da die sind nein es geht
nicht nur um die überfordern
Geldversorgung unserer Amerika sind an
demokratieprojekten beteiligt ich fand
das sehr witzig
die Leute nach Amerika schicken um den
Amis Demokratie beizubringen das ist
wahrscheinlich aber Entschuldigung in
Afghanistan
Stiftung sondern es gab auch eine
Stiftung die Moskau es gibt eine
Stiftung in vielen Staaten wo die
Menschen vor Ort früh sind das ist
Stiftung gibt und ich rede jetzt nicht
nur von der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung
sondern von mir aus auch von anderen
Stiftungen würde ich Ewald Stiftung
damit muss Ansprechpartner haben
besonders gut geklappt die sind dann im
Zweifel diskriminiert worden oder
rausgeschmissen worden das ist natürlich
das Problem die werden ja auch nicht
entschuldigen
neue deutsche Imperialismus also gut
wenn Sie dazu Fragen sollen wir das
irgendwann auch sagen weil dann höre ich
mir das gerne an was sie erzählen von
selbstbedienungsanleitung ja das mache
ich auch schon die ganze Zeit wie Sie
sehen wenn ich anfange zu erklären
werde ich ja unterbrochen aber das ist
jetzt meine Chance mal kurz darauf
hinzuweisen dass wir jetzt immer
springen von dem einen zum anderen diese
Stiftung ich sage das mal
parteiübergreifen kann man kritisieren
aber man sollte zumindest akzeptieren
dass die in weiten Teilen der Welt
wirklich sinnvolle Arbeit machen um
Menschenrechte zu schützen und
demokratische Strukturen zu fördern ob
das immer gelingt ist eine ganz andere
Frage völlig unabhängig davon welche was
ist Anmaßung dass man da dass man da vor
Ort arbeitet und die Leute reden
wirklich von ihrer Diäten
sind weil ich das nicht aber wissen Sie
nur
ein kleines Abhören in Afghanistan hat
eine Stiftung eine
Ausbildung angeboten wie man getrennt
Müll sammelt ja das finde ich ganz
wichtig entscheidend für die
Demokratisierung Afghanistan ich sage
mal voraussetzbar wahrscheinlich nicht
die
ja ich wollte nur mit Herrn Hahne bin
ich der Auffassung dass das in manchen
Ministerien auch mit verhandelndem
Ressourcen
gearbeitet werden könnte ohne dass man
immer was dazu kaufen muss das finde ich
auch das nenne ich aber nicht selbst
bedienungsladen sondern das nenne ich
vielleicht falsche Struktur oder von mir
aus auch eine falsche personellen
aufwuchs der nicht nötig ist gerade in
Zeiten wo man vielleicht mit dem Geld
ein bisschen sparsamer umgehen kann wenn
wir sowieso 500 Milliarden Euro
mittlerweile aufnehmen also der aktuelle
Finanzminister hat so viel Schulden
gemacht in einem Jahr wie in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland von 1949 bis
1990 ob man dann noch bei dieser
Situation zusätzlich in den Ministerien
sich 100 zusätzliche Stellenplan das ist
eine Berechtigung
Schulden und denn genau da sind wir
nämlich bei ihrem Thema jetzt habe ich
mir das mal angeschaut die Verschuldung
die ist Staatsverschuldung versucht man
abzubauen seit Jahrzehnten kann man
sagen
3.744 Euro pro Sekunde nimmt die
Verschuldung zu bei
2,537 Billionen das ist ein gigantischer
Schuldenberg sind wir jetzt und Sie
sagen das darf so nicht weitergehen und
ein großes Problem ist vor allem auch
die Verschuldung der EU sie sorgen sich
massiv damit auch um die Stabilität des
Euro und man muss die Frage aufwerfen
wird der Euro dadurch zu einer Art der
schrottwährung was sollen wir jetzt tun
wie kann man massiv umlenken der Sinn
dass es ihr Thema heute bei uns in der
Sendung ihre Zeit und ihre Kamera
ja was ich da kritisiere ist dass sich
die Länder Europas und auch die EU
indirekt aus der Druckerpresse
finanziert haben wenn ich es mal so ganz
Platz sagen darf was passiert ist man
hat also
keine Steuern erhoben um sinnvolle
Staatsausgaben zu finanzieren sondern
man hat sich verschuldet hat also
Schuldpapiere verkauft an die Banken wo
man Geld zu kommen und die Banken haben
diese Papiere postwendend an ihre
jeweilige nationale Notenbank verkauft
die Bundesbank die Bank hat Italien und
so weiter das heißt letztlich haben die
Staaten sich auf diesem Wege in diesem
indirekten Wege mit der Druckerpresse
finanziert
Druckerpresse muss man jetzt ein
bisschen allgemeiner verstehen das Geld
wird ja heute meistens nicht mehr
physisch gedruckt sondern ist
elektronisch aber von der Sache her ist
es das und da fühle ich mich schon so
ein bisschen erinnert an das was
Nikolaus Kopernikus der erste große
deutsche Ökonomen nicht nur der
Astronomen vor 5
meines Jahre im März war das nämlich
gesagt hat dass die Fürsten immer dazu
neigten ihren Hofstaat mit Gelddruck zu
finanzieren sie kriegt den Zehnten der
zehnte reichen nicht und dann haben Sie
einfach die der das Silber Geld genommen
was in Umlauf war haben das
eingeschmolzen haben ein bisschen mehr
Kupfer und Nickel dazu gegeben und dann
wieder ausgegeben also hatten sie mehr
Geld und konnten also ihren Hofstaat und
ihren Lebensstandard finanzieren
das fehlt im Moment nicht auf aber auf
die Dauer was immer mehr Geld und und
nicht mehr waren und das würde zur
Inflation und es führte dann also auch
vielfach zum Untergang der Währung die
meisten Währung in der Geschichte sind
untergegangen weil die Fürsten sich
bedient haben auf diese Weise und man
kann man sagen lassen ist ja heute
anders heute haben wir jagen
demokratisch kontrolliert das System so
demokratisch ist die EZB gar nicht das
ist auch ein anderes Thema aber die EZB
und mit ihnen die Staaten benutzen also
diesen diese geldschöpfungsmöglichkeit
um dadurch den Staat zu finanzieren und
jetzt haben wir eine große Inflation das
hat indirekt damit zu tun nicht
ursächlich aber es hat insofern zu tun
als eine Inflation entsteht wenn auf den
Märkten eine die Nachfrage größer ist
als das Angebot der Firmen und in der
Pandemie ist jetzt das Angebot gefallen
weil eben Lieferketten Probleme waren
china hat nicht geliefert die helfen
waren zu die Firmen die Fabriken waren
zu es wurde also nicht geliefert die
Einkommen wurden aber trotzdem
aufrechterhalten so als hätte man weiter
produziert und das Geld kam vom Staat
und der hat es sich letztlich von der
Notenbank geholt und da ist also die
eine Diskrepanz entstanden zwischen der
Produktionsmöglichkeit und den künstlich
geschaffenen Einkommen die Nachfrage
sind und das hat die Inflation erzeugt
also noch Platter gesagt die die
Pandemie war so eine Art Zündholz und
der Zunder der da entzündet wurde das
war die so hohe
Nachfrage die die Staaten durch die
Verschuldung letztlich geschaffen haben
und damit sind wir dann doch wieder bei
Kopernikus und bei seinem
inflationsszenarium dass er vor 5001
Jahren sehr plastisch beschrieben hat er
war also wirklich ein Allround-Genie
nicht bekannt ist bei uns
im Bundestag besser geeignet als manche
andere könnte man sagen sie ausgenommen
aber
das ist so die die ewige Wahrheit des
Wirtschaftens mit Geld das diejenigen
die das Geld drucken können das einfach
sinnlich finden sich ein bisschen mehr
zu drucken und fällt ja gar nicht so
weiter auf und die Lasten verteilen sich
also bei einer Steuer schreibt gleich
jemand nein wir nicht die anderen ja es
ist riesen Tor aber wenn man das über
die Verschuldung macht ist das schon
bisschen diffuser und noch diffuser ist
es wenn man dann auch noch die
Druckerpresse mit einsetzt und diese
Schuldpapiere dann gleich an die
Notenbank verkauft dann bleibt das alles
in einem diffusen inflationären Nebel
und keiner weiß so richtig wer der
Verlierer ist und wer die Lasten tragt
aber trägt aber irgendwer trägt sie
natürlich denn der liebe Gott
nimmt ja nicht teil an diesem Prozess
und stellt steckt da keine Ressourcen in
unsere Volkswirtschaft rein die wir
aufessen könnten und den lebensstandort
machen könnten ihre Ansicht nach wird
der Euro damit zerschrottwährung was
bedeutet das für unsere Wirtschaft und
wer trägt dann am Ende diese Schuld also
der Euro ist jetzt genau da wo die
Kritiker zu denen ich damals nicht
gehört muss ich sagen
was die Kritiker befürchtet haben das
ist kein stabiles Währungssystem sein
wird weil eben durch die
Gemeinschaftswährung eine Gemeinschaft
Haftung impliziert für die Schulden
entsteht und diese Gemeinschaft Haftung
verhindert dass ein Land das über die
Stränge schlägt und sich zu stark
verschuldet dann besonders hohe Zinsen
zahlen muss das wäre der natürlichste
Prozess die Gläubiger die Käufer der
Papiere haben irgendwann Angst dass ihr
Geld nicht mehr wieder kriegen
naja also liegen ja auf der Hand hier
die im Mittelmeer Länder Griechenland
war ja im Euro praktisch im Konkurs 2012
also das sind ja klar definierte
schreibt immer schreibt immer so dran
entlang nicht also normalerweise würden
die Märkte
solch einen Schuldenland bestrafen indem
sie höhere Zinsen verlangen weil immer
höheren Schulden wird es immer
unwahrscheinlicher dass das jemand
zurückgezahlt wird und dann würden die
Anleger eine Kompensation in einem
höheren Zins verlangen nicht und das
würde die Länder wieder veranlassen
zurückhaltender zu sein mit der
Verschuldung aber wenn die EZB zur
Verfügung stehen im Kopf die Papiere ja
dann ist ja keine Grenze dann können die
sich so viel Verschulden wie sie wollen
und ja jetzt können die Politiker den äh
so Schulden packte machen wie der Weigel
packt von 1996 der Stabilität und
Wachstumspakt der gesagt hat mehr als
3%, das Bruttoinlandsproduktes ist
verboten sie hat doch keinen Menschen
dieser Pakt ist 200 Mal verletzt worden
150 mal so über einen Daumen gepeilt
verbotener Weise eben es hätte Strafen
geben müssen keine einzige Straße auf
dem Niveau der Mittelmeerländer ja das
sind da kommen wir jetzt langsam hin
also es war ja die Frage ist ist der
Euro nach dem bundesbankprinzip
geschaffen oder nach dem italienischen
Prinzip also Bundesbank mag gleich mag
eine Mark steht immer für die selben
Zahl von Gütern stimmte damals auch
nicht ganz aber von der Idee her die man
damit kaufen kann oder Skala mobile das
heißt hier gehen die Preise hoch dann
gehen die Löhne hoch dann gehen wieder
die Preise hoch Skala mobile heißt heißt
Rolltreppe ja das war so das
italienische System die hat eine
permanente Inflation und haben durch die
Inflation ihre Staatsschulden relativ
zur Wirtschaftsleistung immer gedrückt
die blieben natürlich
nominal gleich aber wenn Inflation ist
dann gehen ja alle Einkommen letztlich
hoch wenn auch mit Verzögerung einige
und relativ zu diesen Einkommen und auch
relativ zum Steueraufkommen des Staates
pulverisieren sich die Schulden und so
haben die Italiener immer gelebt das
Problem ist nur in dieser Inflation
funktioniert die Wirtschaft nicht mehr
richtig weil langfristige
kreditkontrakte nicht mehr funktionieren
wenn ich heute zum in Deutschland zur
Bank ging im deutschen System dann
konnte ich für 20 Jahre 30 Jahren fest
sind ins Kontrakt kriegen ich wusste
also was die Zahlungskonditionen waren
in Italien gibt sowas nicht in Spanien
gibt sowas auch nicht warum nicht weil
die Inflation immer historisch so hoch
war der Gläubiger wusste nicht wie viel
Geld er real also im Kaufkraft gerechnet
zurück kriegt und der Schuldner wusste
nicht wie viel er wirklich zahlen muss
diese Inflation war Sand im Getriebe und
hat dazu geführt dass diese Länder eine
schlechte wirtschaftliche Performance
gekriegt würde ich mal sagen
wegen dem widerstandsministerium
wenn sie in drei Punkte mitgeben das
muss jetzt passieren sonst werden wir da
nicht umlenken ja wir müssen letztlich
das Eurosystem reformieren
Deutschland hat da eine Stimme genauso
wie Malta und wie andere
weichwährungsländer die nicht diese
Präferenzen für Stabilität haben wie wir
wir brauchen eine Stimmrecht nach der
Größe unserer Haftung und die Haftung
geht nach der landesgröße danach müssten
wir also ein Viertel ungefähr haben der
Stimmrechte das wird ein Rassismus
jetzt kommt der andere dran da ist ist
man schnell psychologisch isoliert aber
wenn er Nagel dann noch einen Kollegen
hätte und noch einen und noch einen und
noch einen gemäß der landesgröße dann
könnten die sehr wohl die Stimmung im
EZB-Rat verändern und diese Bundesbank
Stabilitätskultur der Vergangenheit
übertragen man hat jetzt eine
historische Chance
eine solche Reform zu machen denn es
sollen ja sechs Balkanländer in die EU
aufgenommen werden
[Musik]
Herzegowina
Kosovo und so weiter
auch jetzt gerade in den kriegzeiten
Ukraine gesprochen
es spricht schon was dafür sozusagen
hier die rein zu schließen also ich bin
nicht grundsätzlich dagegen aber man
kann diese Länder die dann ja das Recht
haben den Euro einzuführen und das auch
tun kroatien hat jetzt gerade den Euro
gekriegt zum Jahresbeginn die kann man
nicht die gleichen Rechte geben in dem
System wie wieder Bundesrepublik
Deutschland die Bundesrepublik ist ein
Vielfaches an Volumen hat ein Vielfaches
an Volumen wie diese sechs Länder die
dabei treten und trotzdem wird sie dann
massiv dominiert werden im EZB-Rat also
das ist jetzt die historische Chance um
sagen wir machen diese Art von
Erweiterung der EU nur wenn wir das
Regelsystem bei der Gelegenheit auch
ändern aber dann
kann man das schaffen erstmal
jeder deutsche Minister Politiker hat
ein Amtseid geschworen und der Amtseid
lautet Schaden vom deutschen Volk zu
wenden und den Nutzen zu mehren und
dieser Amtseid wird nun seit Jahren
siehe die Flüchtlingspolitik und all
sowas gebrochen in diesem Fall ist es ja
geradezu Himmel schreiend wenn wir uns
in dem gleichen Prinzip jeder hat eine
Stimme aber wir bezahlen ich weiß nicht
wie viel bezahlen wir denn ein Viertel
oder was
zum Beispiel durch die Behinderung die
Marktwerte der Papiere die die EZB
früher gekauft hat runter gehen dann
sind ja voll lustig die tragen wird zum
aber ich bin wirklich der Meinung dann
muss man das ist eine
der Amtseid ist ein Erbe der unseligen
deutschen Geschichte dass wir ihn so
haben und dann muss man ihn abschaffen
also ich bin es langsam leid wenn äh
überall geschworen wird in den den
Schaden zu wenden und es wir sollten
ja
aber ich wissen sie das sind alles
grundsätzliche Sachen sie können nicht
entweder wir nehmen das ernst und sagen
jetzt das hat mit Nationalismus und
sowas gar nicht so und ich denke immer
bei allem auch bei dem Thema mit mit dem
der Einwanderung und Migration an den
schönen Satz von Peter Scholler Tour der
sagt wir können also gerne Kalkutta die
Hälfte von Kalkutta hier aufnehmen nur
dann bleibt Kalkutta Kalkutta und wir
werden Kalkutta und das ist genau auf
diesem ganzen Gebiet wir sind doch
langsam verrückt lassen wir uns mal bei
den beim Thema Wirtschaft vor allem
bleiben und bei dem was der Sinn gerade
geschildert hat man sollte annehmen die
Politik nimmt dieses Thema ernst schauen
wir mal rein
Geld das der Staat ausgibt muss erstmal
erwirtschaftet werden das stimmt so
nicht denn die finanziellen Spielräume
in einem Staatshaushalt die ergeben sich
nicht nur aus den Steuereinnahmen
sondern auch aus der Höhe der Kredite
die man bei der Zentralbank aufnimmt
natürlich müssen diese Kredite auch
zurückgezahlt werden aber man kann
natürlich politisch festlegen zu welchen
Konditionen und in welchen Zeitraum man
sie zurückzahlt man kann in seine eigene
Währung gar nicht pleite gehen man kann
in seiner eigenen Währung gar nicht
pleite gehen deshalb macht das Sinn auch
mal über Kredite die Konjunktur in der
Währung zu stabilisieren
oh Gott das war Jamila Anna Schäfer
grünen Abgeordnete hat Soziologie
Philosophie studiert und sitzt der Sinn
seit 2021 im Bundestag hat sie damit gut
erklärt was sie nicht meinen ja was ich
nicht will ja das ist ja genau die
Mentalität die uns reingeritten hat in
diese inflationäre Welt das geht eben
nicht man kann der liebe Gott ist nicht
zur Verfügung und die Notenbank kann
nicht lieber Gott spielen sie kann zwar
Geld drucken aber sie kann keine echten
Güter machen die man aufessen kann das
kann sie nicht und wenn man das
berücksichtigt dann muss eben das Geld
so knapp sein wie die wirkliche Güter
fällt wieder das Geld darf man nicht
darüber hinaus aussehen und gar nicht
mit diesen Tricks das ist ja das ist
genau das was man was die Politik macht
man druckt sich das Geld für die
Staatsfinanzierung die damaligen gesagt
haben die vom Himmel fallen ja und genau
den Glauben daran aber es ist noch
schlimmer wenn ich das sagen darf wissen
Sie hier ist in der Bundesrepublik der
Sinn fürs Geld einfach verloren gegangen
und die meisten Leute wirklich aus der
Stadt Geld hat und sind überglücklich
wegen seinen neuen euro-ticket Angeboten
bekommen ohne darüber nachzudenken dass
das Geld mit dem das Ticket finanziert
wird Ihnen soeben abgenommen wurde aber
nur über die Inflation das ist ja das
was wir gerade hören ist ja über den
Gelddruck meine ganzen Segen die jetzt
ausgeschüttet werden werden ja davon
finanziert dass den Leuten Steuern
berechnet werden also die Bürger
finanzieren selbst die Sozialleistungen
die der Stadt in einer Zuschauer wenn es
so wäre heute sind wir nicht in dieser
Welt wir sind in einer anderen Welt die
die Bürger zahlen ist nicht in Form von
Steuern sondern die Sparer zahlen ist
durch den Verlust ihres sparvermögens
ihre die Lebensversicherung werden
das Problem der Zukunft sein sagen Sie
sondern heute man sagt über Schulden
sind eine Belastung zukünftiger
Generationen das ist nicht ganz falsch
aber heute in der inflationären Welt
tritt die lassen sofort auf bei denen
die nur Nominalwert gesichert der
Ansprüche haben das sind eben die
kleinen Sparer bereichere Leute können
real sparen die können Aktien kaufen die
sind inflations geschützt aber
ärmere haben ihr Sparbuch oder ihre
Lebensversicherungsverträge und die sind
die gelackmeier die zahlen die Zeche es
gibt aber eine Art von Euphemismus ist
das Ganze befördert der Begriff
Sondervermögen ich weiß nicht ja ich bin
kein Ökonom aber ich kann rechnen 2 + 2
ist noch immer nicht fünf
Sondervermögen zum ersten Mal in der
Geschichte der Nationalökonomie werden
Schulden als Vermögen klassifiziert
nicht zum ersten Mal das macht also
schon lange
wissen sie heitere Fröhlichkeit in der
Kanzler das Wort gebraucht hat
auch eine Infantilisierung des Vorgangs
doppelpunkts und Sondervermögen stellen
sich vor Sie kaufen für zwei Millionen
und das Schulden sind der Bank und dann
sagen sie ihrer Familie ich habe gerade
ein Sondervermögen genau
schlaglistige Täuschung haben wir auch
bei der
Namensbildung bei
eu-vorgängen jetzt sind ja doch für
diese 750 Milliarden schuldentopf der EU
hat man den Begriff Eigenmittel der EU
verwendet deswegen in den Verträgen
ausdrücklich drin die EU darf sich
nur aus Eigenmitteln finanzieren
einmalig ja und zwar nicht aus
Fremdmitteln heißt das Fremdmittel sind
Schulden die Eigenmittel sind aber
Schulden das sind reine Schulden
aufnimmt und wir haften alle
gesamtschuldnerisch dafür ja wir haften
also mindestens wenn wir anteilig haften
für mit unserem was weiß ich 20% 23,6
Prozent mit denen wir dann bei der EU
insgesamt dann da in der Kreide stehen
und wir haften vielleicht sogar noch
mehr wenn nämlich irgendwelche Länder
pleite gehen das ist ja nicht
auszuschließen Griechenland war pleite
im Europa
einmal wurde es vom vom
Direktorium des ESM formell festgestellt
2015 im Sommer sie werden sich erinnern
dass andere Mal war es faktisch so im
Anfang des Jahres 2012 in so einem Land
pleite geht dann kann es ja nicht sich
beteiligen an der Finanzierung dieser
Lasten und dann tragen die anderen die
Last mehr notfalls alleine das heißt
nämlich gesamtschuldnerisch ja
der letzte alleine und wer ist der
letzte kann man sich aushalten und
Wirtschaftskrise haben wir ja mit all
den Schwierigkeiten die damit verbunden
waren ja noch einigermaßen gut geregelt
finde ich jedenfalls wenn die Gefahren
das werden sie wissen besser wissen als
ich waren ja auch nicht gering wenn
nämlich mehrere Länder mal pleite gehen
würden deswegen bin ich immer ich habe
nicht ihren hohen Sachverstand aber ich
glaube die Inflation hat jetzt nicht nur
was mit dem Euro zu tun möglicherweise
auch mit gestiegenden Energiekosten und
mit dem UK also das ist jetzt nur an der
Währung liegt würde ich jetzt auch nicht
so sehen nein nein nein haben sie nicht
gesagt aber sie haben zumindest hätte
man das so verstehen können deswegen lag
mir daran dass zu erwähnen die spannende
Frage ist wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt
sehe ich nicht am Krieg um das mal klar
zu machen
bei der Inflation der gewerblichen
Erzeuger frei waren noch nie so hoch in
der Geschichte
es liegt nicht alles am Euro sondern es
gibt aber überhaupt verschiedene
Faktoren vielleicht kann man sich darauf
verständigen ja und wenn ich jetzt davon
vom deutschen Volker abwenden müssen
dann halte ich das dafür für klug und
sinnvoll diesen einzuschwören
und die spannende Frage ist ja würde es
uns heute besser gehen wäre es besser
wir hätten die Europäische Union nicht
der Schweiz geht Union ist
ohne den Euro
besser funktioniert
im Nachhinein sowieso immer alles besser
zu denen gehört die auch was cool gesagt
hat es wird keine Schuldenunion geben
wir haben das sicher
durchführungskriterien durch die
Maastricht pustekuchen also insbesondere
den Artikel der den b-out also die
Rettung der Schuldner der Gläubiger
eines kaputten Staates verbietet
125 Euro und 123 eurov das keine
monetisierung der Staatsschulden
passieren darf das heißt die Notenbank
darf nicht die die Schuldpapiere kaufen
vielleicht den Unterschied machen Komma
vier Millionen 4400 Milliarden Euro sind
die Papiere gekauft hatte
auch nicht das ist wie mit dem Rührei
sie können aus dem Rührei kann die Eier
nicht wieder herstellen wir sind jetzt
drin in dieser Tinte aber man muss dann
wenigstens versuchen das System langsam
zu verbessern so dass es funktionieren
wenn wir das jetzt einfach zu
pessimistisch ist das ist eine von mir
aus ihrer Analyse es gibt auch ein paar
Kollegen von ihnen die sehen das ein
bisschen anders aber
für sich ich sage ja nur da auch dafür
gibt es möglicherweise unterschiedliche
Faktoren
sozusagen der europäische Binnenmarkt
und das mal zu sagen ist ja eine ganz
grandiose Erfindung gewesen ist weil im
übrigen gegen den Widerspruch der
gesamten linken Politik in Deutschland
weil die ja gegen jede Art von
Freihandel sind beginnt mit
transatlantischen Freihandelsabkommen
oder sowas und endet dann oder begann
eigentlich mit dem europäischen
Binnenmarkt wir als Exportnation
Deutschland sind dermaßen abhängig vom
funktionierenden europäischen
Binnenmarkt im Übrigen hat es auch nicht
geschadet wenn wir dann einheitliche
Währung hatten
währungswechselverluste und alles was
damit zusammenhängt wie gesagt das
können sie besser beurteilen als ich
aber ich bin ich bin auch der Auffassung
dass man nicht alles auch immer im
Nachhinein ist noch einfacher zu
pessimistisch bewertet
werfen die Kritik aber das haben nicht
die Bohne zu tun mit der Kritik an der
EU die EU hat segensreich funktioniert
als Freihandelszone für Europa
verschiedene themenwerte aber alles in
einen Topf mache ich ja aber wir lachen
nur daran dass man das zwischendurch
auch mal sagen
man muss auch immer beim Thema zu
bleiben wenn die EZB sich jetzt
vorgenommen hat die anleihebestände zu
minimieren und abzubauen dann müsste
ihnen das doch auch gefallen
bei dem allgemeinen nicht weil wir haben
ja die Opfer des Schuld sieht nur das
Positive ja nein aber die ähm aber nicht
nur immer vor wir haben ja eben dieses
Wort der Kollegin da aus dem Bundestag
gehört das sind ja die Opfer des
deutschen Schulsystems die da jetzt
sitzen und die und unsere Wirtschaft
geht kaputt verstehen
Wirtschaft geht es in wissen sie werden
es aus ihrem Wahlkreis wissen oder wenn
sie an der Basis sind es gibt heute
Familienunternehmer ich habe muss ich
ihnen das ist ja sehr pathetisch
selten so viele Männer weinen gesehen
wie ihr Lebenswerk innerhalb kürzester
Zeit kaputt geht sie traditionsreiche
Firmen werden liquidiert
Metzgerei im Bäckereien und so weiter
gibt es ja sowieso ein anderes
der Euro geht
Brot kaputt zu gehen und wir sind in der
Gefahr weil sie sagen Exportnation wir
haben ja bald gar nichts mehr zu
exportieren
kaputt nein nein ich meine in
Anführungszeichen
kommen weil sie nicht mehr abwerten
können was sie eigentlich bräuchten um
ihre Wettbewerbsfähigkeit wieder
herzustellen also kompensiert man das
durch Geldtransfers und das Geld wird
dann auch noch aus der Druckerpresse
geholt wie retten sie jetzt die
Wirtschaft ja eigentlich im Prinzip
schon mittendrin in ihrem Thema denn wir
wollen das jetzt immer wieder zurück
nach Deutschland holen und da sagen sie
ganz klar die Ampel die hatte einiges
verkehrt gemacht und wenn wir jetzt so
weitermachen dann wird es mit der
Wirtschaft weiter bergab gehen ich gebe
in ihre Zeit und ihre Kamera mir ging es
vorhin darum dass auch Ludwig er hat
gesagt hat 50% von Wirtschaft ist auch
eine Frage der Stimmung absolut und der
der Philosophie und in der Tat mache ich
mir Sorgen und ich will jetzt gar nicht
sagen dass wir auch so einfach alles ist
die Ampel Schuld die Ampel kann nichts
zu den weltweiten
alten Krisen die entstanden sind wie
haben sich sogar überlappt also wir sind
mit Corona angefangen dann haben wir
jetzt Ukraine daraus zusammenhängt
energiepreiserhöhung aber ich habe schon
das Gefühl dass das viel geredet wird
und dass wir in erster Linie ein
klimaminister haben und keinen
Wirtschaftsminister wenn wir reden
permanent über das Klima so wichtig das
ist ich glaube dass man die Bekämpfung
des Klimawandels kompatibel machen muss
mit wirtschaftlicher Prosperität weil
ich glaube wenn wir den Wohlstand
verlieren dann ist die Bereitschaft
Einbußen hinzunehmen in Bezug auf
Klimawandel und alles was dafür
notwendig ist nicht besonders groß
vorhanden und deswegen kann ich das nur
nüchtern feststellen das ist richtig
analysiert worden auch von großen
Instituten die sagen Deutschland wird
nach hinten durchgereicht wir haben
massive Probleme
ich bedauere genau wie Sie Herr Herne
das insbesondere Familienunternehmen ja
eigentlich auch persönlich haften die ja
eigentlich auch sozusagen das
wirtschaftliche Gerüst dieses Landes
darstellen und nicht in erster Linie
große Manager von großen
Industrieunternehmen auch da wünsche ich
mir dass wir Industrieland bleiben wir
müssen es schaffen Industrieland zu
bleiben und trotzdem sozusagen den
Klimawandel sinnvoll bekämpfen zu können
aber wenn ich jetzt sehe dass wir
ideologisch geprägt bei bei einem
massiven
angebotsnachteil was Energie betrifft
nicht bereit sind darüber nachzudenken
zum Beispiel Kernkraftwerke länger
laufen zu lassen als jetzt bis April
dann habe ich dafür wenig Verständnis
werden angebotsschock feststellt muss
dafür sorgen dass das Angebot erweitert
wird und da kann ich nicht sagen ich
möchte den Lebensraum von henritin nicht
zerstören deswegen darf dürfen
funktionierende Kernkraftwerke die im
Zweifel auch sicher sind
denn das wird er von den TÜV jeweils
überprüft und dann auch noch bestätigt
alles was am Anfang erzählt wurde hat
sich ja nicht so als zutreffend erwiesen
dann verstehe ich nicht dass
offensichtlich Ideologie Vorhang hat vor
Vernunft und manchmal denke ich auch sag
mal der Ideologe der Idiot haben auch
denselben Wortstamm oder ohne das ist
jetzt damit irgendjemanden beleidigen
will oder irgendjemand persönlich meine
dass das ist es nicht ich wünsche mir
einfach dass wir auch bereit sind nicht
ideologisch auf Freihandelsabkommen zu
gucken wie lange haben wir ceta also mit
Kanada ein ein Freihandelsabkommen ein
Land das Europa so ähnlich ist wie kaum
ein anderes auch die gleichen Werte
teilt dass man dafür sieben Jahre
braucht bis man so einen
Freihandelsabkommen abschließt ist mir
ein Rätsel weil es unserer Wirtschaft
nutzt und deswegen glaube ich dass wir
da dass die Ampel jetzt endlich auch
gefragt ist sozusagen von dem von dem
Jahr des erwägens und Abwägens endlich
zum Jahr des Handeln zu kommen und im
übrigen auch ideologische Scheuklappen
abzulegen und endlich das zu tun was die
eigenen die eigenen Wirtschaftsweisen
und Sachverständigen sagen Frau Grimm
einstimmig mit ihrem gesamten Rat der
die Bundesregierung berät
auch lass Energie ja nicht die Chefin
die die sagen alle übereinstimmt lass
die Kernenergie für eine Zeit lang
laufen so lange wie diese Energie
rein ins Wirtschaftsministerium oder
sind sie auch der Auffassung sie sind
fast beim klimaschutzminister zu Gast
sowie das eben gerade ausgeführt wurde
tragen Sie diese Punkte mit rein teilen
Sie die ich kann da nicht drüber reden
im Beirat besprechen das ist eine andere
Geschichte das ist vertraulich und da
kommen zum Schluss Gutachten Texte raus
und die sind dann veröffentlicht wie
kriegen
die Energiewende ist muss auch
nachgebessert werden es ist zwar richtig
dass wir weltweit in eine Energiewende
brauchen aber wir können nicht
unilateral hier in Europa die
Energiewende machen und der Rest der
Welt hustet uns was durch ist wenn wir
jetzt alles wenn wir jetzt die
Brennstoffe für die Autos z.B nicht mehr
verwenden weil wir unsere Autos
Fehlentscheiden mit Strom fahren und der
Strom wird man wegen aus Kohle gemacht
dann was passiert mit den Brennstoffen
die Brennstoffe
bleiben ja nicht in der Erde sondern
die werden über die Marktprozesse in
andere Ländern machen einfach eine Kurve
um Europa und bringen das nach Asien wir
fahren gar nicht erst hier hin um uns
herum nutzen alle Kernenergie ja wie
Schweden die Schweden fangen jetzt neu
an ist ein anderes
und die Ikone der Umweltbewegung Frau
tunberg sagt gerne Energie
nur die deutschen grünen sagen das geht
auch gar keinen Fall der deutschen
Gründe sie haben glaube ich vergessen
werden Atomausstieg durchgezogen
aus meiner Nähe nicht aber
Angela Merkel beschließt und jetzt ist
man ja auch nicht so weit dass man sagt
moment mal wir bauen neue mein Eier
sogar ein bisschen rum mit was soll das
geht um 3 Monate Mama Merkel ist
Geschichte aber wer Gegenwart ist unter
viel schlimmer als
persönlicher hat erklärt
Finanzminister Umweltminister in Bayern
wenn ich sofort die Kernkraftwerke
abgeschaltet werden trete ich zurück ja
lassen sie noch zurückhaltend
wir alle lernen im Laufe der Zeit ja
die richtigen Meinungen sind
abzuschalten
explizit doch dafür aus die habe aber er
ist doch hier inzwischen man kann man
denn jemanden vorwerfen dass er seine
Meinung aufgrund neuer Informationen
geändert hat
Entschuldigung was jemand
bei seiner nein bleibt nein nein also
das wieder da widersprechen und zwar es
ging ja nicht darum um
Wirtschaftlichkeit es ging um Sicherheit
das heißt Herr Söder ist jetzt dafür
dass die von ihm als unsicher
dargestellt Energie jetzt plötzlich
angeschaltet hat vielleicht neue
Informationen dass das mit der
Sicherheit
das kann es doch geben auch dazu gelernt
aber nein lieber Herr aber wir haben uns
sehr nein also das lasse ich mir jetzt
nicht anhängen wenn es das müssen
Söder damals gesagt hätte wir brauchen
aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen weil wir
Alternativen haben keine Atomkraftwerke
dann würde ich sagen wunderbar wenn man
die Meinung dann revidiert aber
die Gefährlichkeit aber Ehrlichkeit muss
man auch abwägen und jetzt nicht mehr
gefährlich doch aber wir haben uns mit
anderen Gefahren zu tun mit Putin haben
wir es zu tun und den Gefahren die mit
dem Krieg zu tun haben und so weiter das
heißt also auch man muss diese
verschiedenen neuen
gefahrengeschichte alles im Leben ist
gefährlich wenn ich die Straße über klar
ist das auch bei mir offene Türen ein
aber ich heiße ja nicht Söder
dazu na die CDU ist in der Lage
offensichtlich auf veränderte
Rahmenbedingungen auch eine veränderte
Politik zu machen wenn man wenn man dazu
nicht in der Lage ist kann man in der
Tat zu Hause bleiben ja das meine ich
aber denn wir hatten diese Bedingungen
und das ist ein Krieg in Europa in dem
Ausmaß geben würde war zum Zeitpunkt wo
sich auch Frau Merkel entschieden hatte
damals als Kanzlerin aus der kennen
Energie auszusteigen ob das jetzt
richtig oder falsch war in meiner
Fraktion haben das auch viele anders
gesehen und das mal klar zu sagen aber
ja die sehen das auch heute noch anders
der der fakt ist nur deswegen stört mich
das so ein bisschen wenn man nur
zurückguckt wenn sie nur in den
Rückspiegel gucken fahren
ist zum Beispiel auch bereit den Ausbau
voranzutreiben so wie Frankreich das
gerade also mein Fraktionsvorsitzender
hat sich da klar positioniert er hat
auch nicht rum wie sie ist glaube ich
vorhin erwähnt habe aber das hat man
glücklicherweise nicht gehört weil die
beiden Herren sicher gestritten
aber das war ja tatsächlich noch am Ende
des vergangenen Jahres so dass er gesagt
hat der Zug ist da abgefahren es wird
nichts mehr Verlängerung aktuell ganz
klar gesagt versteht nicht ja er
versteht nicht dass man im
Bewusstsein einer massiven Energiekrise
eines angebotsschocks nicht alle alle
Energiequellen nutzt das ist unsere
Auffassung dazu gehört irgendwie nicht
nur Kernkraft sondern auch regenerative
Energien
ich meine das ist ja noch das lustig so
dass die Kernkraftwerke ablehnen aber
Braunkohle und Kohlekraft weiter im
Betrieb im CO2 schädlich ohne Ende
deswegen sind die Grünen aus meiner
Sicht auch in den der Hinsicht keine
überzeugende umweltschutzpartei mehr
sondern nur noch eine an die AKW
Parteien
ganz klar gesagt wir haben jetzt erstmal
gesagt als cdu/csu und in persona meines
Vorsitzenden dass wir für eine begrenzte
Zeit warum und wieder begrenzte Zeit ja
ich sollte ich sollte ja jetzt mal
schildern was mein fraktionsvorsitzer
gesagt hat damit er damit das jetzt kein
verständliche gibt ja die habe ich auch
wenn wenn wir eine neue Generation von
von Kraftwerken haben muss man sich auch
angucken was entsteht dann noch wie
sicher sind die das sind Fragen die muss
man den muss man sich dann auch neu
stellen aber weil nach unserer Position
gefragt wurde die ist eindeutig dass wir
sagen angesichts derzeitigen Situation
brauchen wir einen längeren Betrieb der
Kernkraftwerke bis 2024 damit wir in der
Lage sind die durch den Ukraine Krieg
entstehenden Energie
Probleme zu lösen im Übrigen noch mal
nicht nur kennen Energie sondern ein
breites Angebot wir müssen jede Chance
nutzen denn das es gibt viele es gibt 24
ist einfach nur die mit und dumm ja
müssen sie sich doch kommen
nächstes Jahr wollen sie sagen jetzt
aber noch ein Ja sagen ja machen sie es
doch also wenn sie mir genau zugehört
haben haben sie vielleicht auch zugehört
oder gehört dass ich gesagt habe solange
wir diese Energiekrise haben und das ist
Teil dieser Geschichte
die baut keine neuen Kernkraftwerke das
hat ja auch übrigens nur Sinn wenn man
die jetzt laufen lässt endlos also
Entschuldigung wenn wir jetzt an diesem
Tisch sind sie haben mir darauf
hingewiesen Herr Söder ist ja so
großartig der ist ja jetzt hat sich
bekehrt sozusagen zur Kernenergie das
heißt ja zu deutsch wenn ich jetzt
anschalte gehe ich davon aus riesigen
gibt's überall sie Bergwerk Unglücke sie
ist sinnvoll und sie ist sicher und ich
kann das anschalten und dann frage ich
mich die Begrenzung ist doch absolut
bescheuert wenn ich dieser Meinung bin
sage ich ich lass die so lange laufen ja
sie ist ja nicht sicher das weiß doch
jeder das sie nicht sicher ist aber sie
ist auch nicht so unsicher wie die Leute
tun
die meisten Leute sterben relativ zu
erzeugen
sondern das ist die Kohle das Sterben
150.000 Leute jedes Jahr 100.000 davon
an Lungenkrebs 20.000 kommen in den
Minen um und vor allem auch bei der
Grünen Energie haben wir das Problem des
da auch leider Tote gibt relativ zu dem
bisschen Energie was da erzeugt wird
sind es viele Tote die stehen an der
Spitze der Statistik jeder möge bitte
googeln Statista Tote bei der
Energieerzeugung dann sieht deine
Tabelle weil die Klempner eben vom Dach
fallen ja das ist ja also es ist super
Energie wenn ich das in Relation nehme
dann sind sie wieder an der Spitze und
sie kriegen also
aus ich hoffe er kriegt zwei
ich habe in meinem Dorf 3
was was
machen die Frage beantworten wir gleich
wir sind gleich zurück weil 8:15 Uhr und
dann fragen wir uns im übrigen was läuft
denn noch gut in Deutschland nicht mehr
so viel funktioniert das sagt zumindest
Peter Halle bis gleich
[Musik]
alles Verantwortlich wird heiß weiter
diskutiert auch während der Pause und
jetzt fragen wir uns was funktioniert
eigentlich noch in Deutschland ja gut
die Wahl in der Hauptstadt nicht ganz so
gut in die wird ja jetzt am Sonntag auch
wiederholt und auch ansonsten gibt es
nicht so viel was gerade wirklich rund
läuft dass das Bild das Peter jetzt beim
Thema
vielen Dank Patricia also ähm
für mich ist es interessant vor allem
wenn man in der Schweiz ist zu sehen die
Stabilität und Funktionalität eines
Staates kann man erkennen an der Bahn in
der Schweiz ist die nicht minütlich
pünktlich sondern Sekunde auf die
Sekunde genau
man erkennt auch den Zustand
Deutschlands am Zustand der Bahn ich
habe mir nun erlaubt vorgestern mal
wieder Bahn zu fahren und ich habe sie
mir extra aufgeschrieben was ich da
erlebt habe nämlich falsches sage also
doch nach Erfurt sollte um 10:30 Uhr
gehen ähm war auch alles so keine an
Tage kein gar nichts denn wenn eine
Ansage der Verspätung gekommen wäre
hätte man vorher mit einem anderen sucht
fahren können also es gab nichts dann
gab es Verspätung in zehn Minuten
Rhythmus zu plus 45 Minuten
die Ansage lautet der einmal eine
beschädigte Brücke danach kam
Gleisarbeiten danach kam die Ansage
schuld ist ein vorausfahren dazu
im Zug habe ich dann erfahren durch die
Ansage es sei ein Defekt am Triebwerk
des gesamten Zuges ich bekam dann eine
SMS obwohl man ja schon im Zug saß dass
eine Verspätung zu erwarten sei Grund
eine Reparatur an der weiche also das
ist so die Gesamtdarstellung sie können
sich aussuchen ja und mir sagt ein so
und jetzt ging es aber noch weiter
willkommen im Bistro so ungefähr nach
dem Motto jetzt müssen sich mal ein
bisschen erholen wegen der Verspätung
nach 5 Minuten kommt die Durchsage meine
Damen und Herren es tut mir furchtbar
leid im Bistro gibt es technische
Störungen mit der
elektrozufuhr das Bistro ist geschlossen
so jetzt frage ich die Bahn gott sei
Dank hat man ja überall Verbindungen
untersagt mir ein führender bahnmensch
lieber Herr Herne alles stimmt alles
jeder einzelne denn die Bahn ist marode
die gesamte Infrastruktur ist letztlich
kaputt und
in Leipzig ging es dann weiter da hieß
es dann plötzlich der Zug kann nicht
weiterfahren weil er jetzt insgesamt
kaputt ist
per Ferndiagnose wurde dann das so und
jetzt freue ich mich ja dass er große
Brömer da ist denn
das sind 16 Jahre CSU Verkehrsminister
16 Jahre hat die Union Verantwortung
getragen für die Bahn bis in die Spitze
sogar der Firma hinein wir erleben eine
völlig marode Geschichte die können wir
jetzt nicht bei der Ampel abladen
wir haben über die Energie gesprochen
diese ganze Energiewende ist ja
angefangen bei ihren Truppen da war gar
kein grüner dran beteiligt in der
Bundesregierung die gab es noch gar
nicht die Bundeswehr dass sie die völlig
zugrunde gerichtet worden ist die arme
Frau Lambrecht die hat mir richtig leid
getan die war ja nur noch das
Sahnehäubchen auf dem real existierende
Dilettantismus sie hatten einen
Gutenberg der die die größten Sündenfall
mit Beifall der CDU nämlich die
Abschaffung der Wehrpflicht danach
hatten sie so leuchten wie Ursula von
der Leyen die wurden als Belohnung und
noch Königin von Europa und ähm Frau AKK
ähm Frau Lambrecht war ja nur noch das
Sahne Häubchen da drauf sie haben im
Endeffekt auch was wir jetzt eben
besprochen haben was Energie angeht uns
an Russland verkauft wieso waren wir
denn abhängig von Russland wir sind
abhängig von China was Elemente angeht
ja das ist das was die Leute vor Ort
erleben und das kann man nicht rausreden
ich will nur verstehen sie dann verstehe
ich diesen peinlichen Populismus von dem
geschätzten Friedrich beherzt nicht der
von kleinen Paschas spricht wer hat denn
die kleinen Paschas im Rahmen der
Grenzöffnung 2015 unkontrolliert hier
reingelassen das waren auch keine grünen
sondern es war die damalige Koalition
und sie hatten als cdu/csu die
Weisungsbefugnis durch das
Bundeskanzleramt und auch die
Fachminister Verteidigung innen und für
die Bahn den Verkehrsminister wenn Sie
heute ihren Wahlkreis fahren ich weiß
nicht Sauerlandlinie da können sie dann
vor Lüdenscheid abfahren weil nämlich
die Brücke kaputt ist also ich wohne
kurz vor Hamburg aber das wäre der Umweg
mehr zu groß ich war seit vielen Jahren
waren und ich kann Ihre verär über diese
Zuständigkeit man verstehen ja aber du
erzählen sie jetzt nicht dass es alles
an die scheuer oder sonst wer Schuld es
hat massive Investitionen in die
Deutsche Bahn gegeben ob die immer
richtig ausgegeben wurden müssen sie mal
den Vorstand Fragen der Deutschen Bahn
daran daran war ich leider nicht
beteiligt aber da das wäre nämlich
wesentlich besser aber sie saßen doch da
in den ich will nein
keine
Vergangenheitsbewältigung oder was
machst du so sondern die Reden nein nein
nein mit dieser Hotze wie sich heute
bestimmte Leute von der Union hinstellen
in diesem deutschen Bewusstsein wir
waren bei allem nicht dabei oder wir
haben von allen nicht gewusst das finde
ich einfach schlimm ähm
und sie haben aber einen Vorteil
deswegen wollen wir geil auf zu reden
die größte Pandemie aller Zeiten dagegen
ist ja Corona eine leichte Grippe ist
die volksdemenz wir haben eine
politische Demenz unter den in der
Bevölkerung die werden treu und brav
auch in Berlin jetzt wieder alles wählen
über dass sie sich an sich aufgeregt
haben
einiges gegen sie die Energiewende die
Aussetzung Deutsche Bahn wir haben wir
haben uns abhängig gemacht von von
Russland ich meine die Wahrheit ist
folgendes in Nord Stream 1 hat eine
rot-grüne Regierung geschlossen und Frau
Merkel hat lediglich auf den Knopf
gedrückt
darauf antworten
immer nur zu sagen ja das war der und
der und der sondern die Frage ist wie
geht's in die Zukunft weiter noch mal
der Rückspiegel aus Fehlern ja aber das
muss ich aber dann sagen wenn das immer
so so lange eingeworfen wird das war
alles ähm Mama Merkel oder sowas
ist mir egal
cdu/csu ja ja sie haben nur Stream 1 ein
Beschluss einer rot-grünen Regierung
Verkauf von von von Gas Speichern von
von Sigmar Gabriel der die Abhängigkeit
kann durch Livestream 2 gar nicht
entstanden sein weil da überhaupt gar
kein Gas geflossen ist zur Bahn habe ich
gesagt ich verstehe ihren Ärger aber da
muss dann möglicherweise im Vorstand was
falsch gelaufen sein zwei Milliarden
Investitionen in die Bahn jedes Jahr
kann man sagen
ja die Bahn ich ich fahre seit vielen
vielen Jahren waren es gibt auch
tatsächlich noch Züge die pünktlich sind
man kann darüber streiten ob die
ausreichend sind oder nicht ich teile
ihren Ärger und ich bin sehr dafür dass
wir manches verbessern und besser machen
aber das jetzt immer nur irgendwie ein
Verkehrsminister daran schuld ist und
sozusagen die die die die faktische
Organisation durch den Vorstand damit
überhaupt gar keine Rolle spielt können
wir gerne darüber diskutieren
bin ja erstmal Bahnfahrer und also das
auch so nachvollziehen wie es hier
geschildert wird es funktioniert selten
mal alles irgendwas ist immer kaputt
meistens und und zu spät kommt tun die
Züge und wenn es weniger sechs Minuten
ist gilt das als pünktlich das ist aus
Schweizer Sicht und denkbar da fahren
die Züge auf die Sekunde
ja also das woran liegt das äh ich muss
mal was sagen was sie gar nicht von mir
erwarten würden ich glaube der es war
ein Fehler die Bahn zu privatisieren
ich habe eine Studie
herausgegeben auf Englisch ist das mit
dem englischen Kollegen wo wir also da
ist die Bahn jetzt gerade nicht so gut
ja eben eben wo wir also für alle
europäischen Länder einen Fachmann
gebeten haben da einen Bericht zu
schreiben und zu sagen wo hat denn die
Privatisierung funktioniert und wo nicht
und da kam heraus funktioniert hat sie
immer nur da wo anschließend Wettbewerb
geschaffen werden konnte aber Verband
können Sie keinen sinnvollen das Netzes
ja nur einmal da also das ist schwierig
da geht das mit den Zügen auf dem aber
dann passt die Präsentation getrennt von
zu ja das ist alles Käse funktioniert
überhaupt nicht und sie haben also
eindeutig gesehen dass alle Länder die
die Bahn privatisiert haben damit auf
dem Bauch gefallen sind das hat also
nicht funktioniert man hätte im
Nachhinein ist man immer schlauer das
ist ja auch gut man muss dann nur draus
lernen und Konsequenzen ziehen man hätte
damals
die staatliche Bahn nicht abschaffen
dürfen ist heute meine Meinung ich war
auch damals nicht so habe ich mich nicht
anders geäußert aber auch war hatte
keine klare Meinung aber nach der Studie
habe ich sie und man hätte den
Beamtenstatus lassen müssen denn der
Beamtenstatus hat ein internes
Anreizsystem für
pflichtgetreues Verhalten ja es gibt
eine Förderung und es gibt auch Strafen
im beamtensystem das ist über
Jahrhunderte gewachsen darauf hätte man
auch mal bauen können das ist glaube
nämlich das Hauptproblem das aber heute
ein Personal haben
nicht immer entfernt das denn an die das
Pflichtbewusstsein des alten
Beamtenstatus heran aber das sage ich
nicht so Infrastruktur
ich bestreite das ist ein Thema der
infrastrukturform
kaputt
nein das Personal ist nicht mehr das nur
nicht morgen wieder das Beamten
sechs Jahren
das ist vielleicht politisch nicht
korrekt das zu sagen aber das ist der
Schluss den ich aus unseren Studien da
ziehe das war also ein historischer
Fehler damals diese allgemeinen
Privatisierung zu machen man hätte das
genauer unterscheiden müssen Telekom hat
ja funktioniert da haben wir
wettbewerblich Post haben wir auch im
wettbewerbliche zuständig immer wenn
Wettbewerb möglich ist funktioniert das
mit der Privatisierung aber die Bahn ist
nun das muss dabei Beispiel dafür dass
es nicht möglich ist weil es ein großes
Netz ist und die Infrastruktur ein
Gebäck ein Kern einer Industrienation
wenn das nicht funktioniert wie weh tut
das unserer Wirtschaft wie weh tut das
Deutschland wenn das nicht funktioniert
ja das tut uns alles zunehmend weh und
das liegt ja das geht ja weiter also der
öffentliche Sektor funktioniert auch
insgesamt nicht mehr wir sind hier in
Berlin
Geburtsurkunde ein halbes Jahr Liebe
also ich komme aus Bayern ich bin kein
Bayern ich bin Westfalen aber lebe in
Bayern da funktioniert das halt noch was
hier schon lange nicht mehr funktioniert
ein halbes Jahr für den Geburtsurkunde
ja in Bayern das muss ich sagen ja
alles funktioniert nicht alles aber
ziemlich viel Vergleich zu Berlin
funktioniert alles
also Wahlen insbesondere ich liebe diese
Stadt ich bin sehr ewig gewesen schon
ich finde ja auch toll DDR-Zeit weil wir
viele Verwandten hier hatten er hat
meine Tanten geliebt Berlin liebe ich
als Stadt Arbeit über diese Stadt geht
doch den Bach runter das funktioniert
die in der
infrastrukturierende Straßen geschlossen
für Verkehr ja das muss man auch erstmal
schauen ja das ist ein Glück dass wir
jetzt nicht gemeckert funktionierende
Straßen fahren kann ohne ohne
irgendwelche
Schwierigkeiten werden einfach dich
gemacht Entschuldigung und
Berlin gibt es lauter Hartz IV Empfänger
tja die sind man ist nicht in der Lage
das System so zu organisieren dass der
Schnee Schnee weggeräumt gibt es mehr
unbegreiflich wie
ineffizienter ja man Fliege mal von
Berlin von dem Flughafen entfernen das
ist solch eine Katastrophe das Vermeiden
man muss das vermeiden
Sie wissen doch dass ein Drittel des
Flughafens Herr scheuer und der Dobrindt
werden
ich höre nicht zur CDU nein nein nein
immer schnell das ist wohlerei und so
weiter lassen Sie doch das Problem weg
das spielt keine Rolle wer hier
verabschiede mich schon eine Rolle
inhaltlich gemacht wo muss man ansetzen
um zu korrigieren das können Sie aber
nur wenn Sie den Fehler benennen aber
Sie müssen sich auch Personen benennen
doch nein das muss man nur im Parteien
gezwängt es geht aber um mehr als
Parteien das geht darum den Laden wieder
in es geht um Kompetenz es geht darum
dass die Parteien inklusive der in dem
Falle in kriminierten Leute sie wollen
doch wohl nicht behaupten dass Frau von
der Leyen und Frau ATK die Namen Weg das
ist nicht aber das ist überhaupt
Personen am argumentieren
nein das ist nicht in Ordnung
Deutschland ist in einer schwierigen
Situation wo wir den Laden in Ordnung
bringen müssen
mit persönlichen Beschuldigungen sie
können nicht sagen er soll die
Personalfrage weglassen wenn sie bei der
Bundesbahn das zentrale Problem beim
Personal sehen ja aber nicht Personen
haben keine
Individuen diese Person hat die falsche
Entscheidung getroffen
Personalproblem sie können nicht mal
einen ganz guten Nachfolger für Gott sei
Dank für eine Fernsehshow die
Personaldecke ist so dünn das Frau 16
Jahre machen konnte und jetzt tritt ihre
Nachfolger sie haben mir ein generelles
Personalproblem es hat auch was damit zu
tun dass bei 100000 Leute und zwar die
qualifizierten jedes Jahr in Deutschland
verlassen ja das ist richtig Probleme
haben wir wir haben Personen
haben
nein Entschuldigung ist mir zu billig
lieber
Instituts wenn ich
Fehler entdecke die in ihrer
Verantwortung sind sage ich doch nicht
da war irgendein Herr der auf Westfalen
stammt und in Bayern lebt und Berlin so
toll findet sondern dann sage ich den
Namen und wer sich in die Öffentlichkeit
wagt und wer die ein solches Amt
übernimmt muss Verantwortung übernehmen
das Problem ist doch heute so zu
übernehmen
irgendwie Verantwortung zu tragen und
irgendwie musste derjenige der
verantwortlich ist diese eben auch
tragen und ohne Name natürlich dann muss
man den auswechseln wenn es nicht
funktioniert aber nächste Woche den
gleichen Fehler vielleicht ist es ist
eine Frage der Stimmungslage in diesem
Land dass wir träumen über einen
Wirklichkeit die man schaffen könnte
durch bloße Wünsche irgendwas die
Realität ist eine ganz andere die
wirtschaftliche Realität liegt die muss
stärker berücksachen haben wir leben in
einer Demokratie und jeder Politiker
insbesondere jeder Kanzler oder jede
Kanzlerin übernimmt schon dadurch
Verantwortung dass sie sich wie Frau
Merkel dreimal einer Wahl stellt und
wenn Sie eine Mehrheit bekommen für ihre
Politik dann hat sie sowohl beim
Wahlkampf als auch darüber hinaus
Verantwortung übernommen ist sie auch
bestätigt worden weil offensichtlich
manche auch der Meinung waren einmal
über 40 Prozent sie macht den Job gar
nicht so schlecht manche sind können
unterschiedliche Auffassung sein
das sind ja normal Fakten daran kann ja
nichts ändern
mit Angela Merkel mit der ehemaligen
Kanzlerin ist 2015 wir schaffen das hat
sie damals gesagt acht Jahre später
stehen wir vor einer ähnlichen Situation
Hendrik ein Bruder sagt ganz klar wir
schaffen das nicht und damit sind wir
bei Ihnen Thema vielleicht schaffen wir
das schon aber zumindest nicht mit
dieser Innenministerin weswegen ich
dafür bete sie möge in Hessen
kandidieren und da gewählt werden
Restaurant also keine SPD in Hessen ja
in Hessen
nein mein Thema ist Nancy Faeser ich
gebe zu schon beim Namen Nancy stolperei
ich ich finde das muss nicht sein
Natalie wäre viel schöner aber
es ist so die prominenteste
filmbesetzung diesem Kabinett schauen
Sie sie hat jetzt zu einem
migrationsgipfel aufgerufen bei dem
flüchtlingsgipfel ich habe kurz mal
einen zweiten nachgesehen was das alles
für Gipfel gegeben hat in diesem Land
digital Gipfel mobilitätsgipfel
sportgipfel gesundheitsgipfel
Bildungsgipfel ernährungsgipfel und
jetzt ist ein biergipfel im geredet weil
das Bier so teuer wird und die
Brauereien haben sie schon an Kanzler
Scholz Gewand im Bürger Eingreifen in
diesem Land ist alles Chefsache und da
kommt Frau Feser mit der fantastischen
Idee dass man zum Beispiel damit hat sie
sich wirklich ernsthaft beschäftigt die
Unschuldsvermutung aufheben sollte und
Beamte die verdächtigt werden könnten
nicht statt tragen genug zu sein müssen
ihre Unschuld beweisen die
Unschuldsvermutung ist eine der Säulen
des Rechtsstaates und die
Innenministerin die wir die Verfassung
wacht bricht dieser Regel genauso witzig
war ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben als
sie gesagt hat der es geht jetzt wir
haben einen neuen Tatbestand ins
Gespräch eingeführt es gäbe ein
Verfassungsschutz relevante
Delegitimierung des Staates das gibt es
nicht das ist kein Tatbestand da steht
in keinem Strafgesetzbuch das ist eine
reine Disziplin andorische Erfindung um
Kritik am Start in die Nähe von
Kriminellen Verhalten zurück rücken sie
können ja auf die Straße gehen und sagen
diese Stadt ist scheiße das ist nicht
strafbar da werden so
Bundesratspräsident das kann sein nein
da müssen sie da müssen Sie schon rufen
Deutschland verrecken andere
vorbereitet geredet mir alle dazwischen
ja und das ist der schönste Satz von
Frau Feser nämlich zu den
Demonstrationen im Sommer mit Corona sie
hat wirklich gesagt und sie hat gesagt
man kann schon seine Meinung kundtun
ohne sich gleichzeitig an vielen Orten
zu versammeln
bleiben
eine Schüssel mit Salzstangen nebenbei
und eine Flasche Bier oder gleich ein
Fässchen Bier und dann halten sie ein
Schild in die Höhe bin dagegen oder was
auch immer man kann seine Meinung auch
kund und ohne sich gleichzeitig an
vielen Orten sondern leben ja Sessel zu
Hause
abzuschließen ich ich schätze die Frau
sehr weil sie wirklich denn erbärmlichen
Zustand der Politik hier auf den Punkt
bringt und deswegen muss auch der Name
genannt werden und inzwischen bin ich zu
der Überzeugung gekommen
Frau Feser ist ein Fall für den
Verfassungsschutz die Art wie sie mit
der Verfassung umgeht die Art wie sie
neue Tatbestände formuliert ist
eindeutig verfassungsfeindlich wir haben
also raus Herr Bruder sie sind ein
riesen Fan von Nancy fazer so kann man
das sagen schließen Sie sich diesen
Fanclub an gerne aber selbstverständlich
also verstehen sie das ist wenn
Ideologie und Dummheit zusammenkommen
dann wird es wirklich gefährlich das ist
also schon fast ein Kriegszustand und
wir erleben in vielen Dingen solange das
noch die Opposition war da konnte man
sagen da können die doch sagen was sie
wollen aber wenn ich an den Hebeln der
Macht sitze und dann auch noch
Ministerpräsident werden will das ist
einmal dumm weil ich weder meinen
Amtseid noch die Verfassung noch
irgendwelche rechts und sie meinte diese
zwei Sachen verbinden das ist das tolle
und es gibt übrigens in der Aufstellung
der Reisen von Frau Feser und auffällig
oft hat sie Hessen besucht um dort
Regierungsgeschäfte wahrzunehmen
so ein Zufall also meine Bitte an die
Lieben bitte bitte
heute nennen sie heil weil auf Ruf quasi
Herr sind für sie ist glaube ich dieses
Gespräch genau das was sie nicht hören
wollten das wird das genau auch
verknüpft mit einem Namen mit der
Innenministerin Nancy Fehse aber es
wurden ja auch ganz sachlich einige
Themen benannt der zweite
flüchtlingsgipfel die Kritik am ersten
da kamen nicht genug bei rum erkennen
Sie diese Kritik an
der Flüchtlingsfrage da bin ich schon
auch ihrer Meinung Bruder das wir hier
ein Problem haben Deutschland
hat sehr viel
sozialen Migration gehabt nicht dass
Leute aus bedrängten Ländern fliehen
weil sie nur den Sozialstaat suchen aber
sie haben ja die die Wahl zwischen
verschiedenen Ländern auf der Welt mit
mehr oder weniger sozial sind wenn sie
dann schon mal vertrieben sind von zu
Hause dann gehen Sie natürlich in das
Land dass die großzügigsten
Sozialleistungen hat
dabei und das ist schon ein Problem man
kann nicht ein Sozialstaat grundsätzlich
haben der seine Leistungen im Prinzip
für jeden zur Verfügung stellt der da
kommt das Geld reicht hinten und vorne
nicht und es wird ja auch zu einer
Fehlentwicklung insofern als die Leute
sich dann nicht nach ihrer Produktivität
und nachdem was sie wirklich beisteuern
schon entscheidend für den
Start der Wahl sondern nachdem wo die
meisten sozialgeschenke kommen über das
Umverteilungssystem des Staates wir
brauchen ja eine Umverteilung von von
oben nach unten weil die Marktwirtschaft
des nicht von alleine hinreichend gut
leistet ja die Marktwirtschaft entlohnt
nach Knappheit und Knappheit hat wenig
mit Gerechtigkeit zu tun also das ist
ein Konsens man nimmt das Geld von oben
und gibt es unten aber wenn man dann
jetzt auch noch die Grenzen aufmacht und
jeder der rein kommt hat dann auch die
Möglichkeit
so sich
versorgen zu lassen wie die anderen dann
ist es ja kein Versicherungsprinzip
werden nicht der Sozialstaat ist eine
Versicherung auf Gegenseitigkeit gegen
Unglücke im Leben solche hat er seine
wirkliche Funktion aber kein
Versicherungssystem funktioniert wenn
sie sagen die schlechten Risiken dürfen
nach Belieben in das
versicherungskollektiv Eintreten es geht
nicht und dazu kommt dass ähm Politik
verantwortliche Politik dafür sorgen
muss dass die Stimmung im Land nicht
kippt ich erinnere mich an Wolfgang
Schäuble der vor vielen vielen Jahren
als das losging mal in einem Gremium der
evangelischen Kirche wo ja auch also nur
wir brauchen Flüchtlinge und ist alles
so wunderbar gesagt hat für ihn sei das
oberste Prinzip wie viel Toleranz
verträgt ein Volk
und wenn wir auch umkippt das kann ja
und genau das
wir können irgendwann amerikanische
Verhältnisse kriegen das müssen auch
viele Leute müssen die sehen die diesen
Kurs offen mit Multikulti und so weiter
offen vertreten das funktioniert nicht
so gut ich habe in Amerika gelebt da
gibt es die Slums da gibt es enorm
Unterschiede da gibt es Spannungen
worüber das deutsche Fernsehen nicht
berichtet hat im letzten Abends ja von
Trump gab es ja die Aufstände in den
Innenstädten die Supermärkte brannten
das waren jetzt nicht die Trump Leute
die integriert haben auch etwas anders
in Deutsch ja wenn ich mich recht
erinnere die Amerikaner bräuchten
dringend einen Sozialstaat um das
abzufedern das ist immer meine Kritik an
den Amerikanern gewesen aber es wird
immer schwieriger wenn die ethnischen
Unterschiede groß sind weil dann die
einen sagen ich bin nicht bereit für die
andere jetzt Geld auf dem Tisch zu leben
es wird dann zu Spannungen und zu einer
Ablehnung des Sozialstation der
Sozialstaat geht auf diese Weise vor die
Hunde also zu viel Wünsche
Diversifizierung hat in einem Land das
muss man braucht Immigration Deutschland
hat zu wenig Kinder das wissen wir alle
die Babyboomer kommen in die Kürze in
die Rente und wollen ernährt werden von
Kindern die sie nicht haben also
brauchen wir Migranten wir müssen uns
die Migranten richtig aussuchen wir
brauchen einen Punktesystem das ist ja
lange diskutiert worden aber diese
zufallsmigration von denen die ganz
unten in das System einsteigen und dann
für die sich das dann lohnt weil sie
durch die sozialverteilung die
Umverteilung des Sozialstaates dann
profitieren das ist nicht das Richtige
selektionskriminieren
Kanzlerin 2015 geschaffen das das würden
sie heute anders formulieren ich bin im
Gegensatz zu ihrem Bruder bereit Frau
fieser bis zur nächsten Bundestagswahl
als Innenministerin zu akzeptieren weil
ich glaube der hessische
Ministerpräsident macht gerade einen
guten Job und der hat nie wieder Wahl
verdient
und
wir haben natürlich gelernt
dass das was frau Merkel damals gemacht
hat mit mit der cdu/csu-fraktion nämlich
Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen aus Budapest
deutlich richtig war ich glaube dass der
daraus resultierende im übrigen auch mit
Hilfe der Bild ich kann mich noch ein
riesen Button erinnern Review refugees
welcome ja dem saß dann der damalige
Minister Gabriel auf der Regierungsbank
groß mit Bild unterschrieben kommt alle
zu uns dass dieser Eindruck entstanden
ist war aus meiner Sicht falsch denn wir
können bei aller Liebe und das glaube
ich kann man nicht schöner formulieren
als er damalige bundespräsident Gauck
der gesagt hat unser Herz ist groß aber
unsere Möglichkeiten sind begrenzt und
das muss man auch ehrlich sagen weil man
braucht die Akzeptanz der Menschen für
eine Integration und da ist es völlig
unstreitig dass wir im Jahr man sagt so
rund 400 000 höre ich immer im Jahr an
Zuwanderung brauchen aber natürlich in
den Arbeitsmarkt natürlich
wir brauchen wir qualifizierte Leute und
die kommen komischerweise nicht da muss
ich auch mal fragen warum ja da muss man
fragen woran liegt das das liegt
natürlich an vielen wandern gerade
Montag mit Vertretern einer der der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit gesprochen das
beginnt mit der Sprache das ist
schwierig in Deutschland weil wir auch
sagen du musst erstmal die Sprache
können als Grundvoraussetzung der
Integration das schreckt viele ab manche
mit Englisch ist es einfacher die suchen
sich dann andere Länder aus aber da
müssen wir halt besser werden und wir
brauchen auch weil wir immer wieder
feststellen wir sagen dann ist auch ganz
wichtig die die zu uns kommen müssen
sich hier auch an unsere Regeln halten
insbesondere an an Gesetze und wer das
nicht ja ja
voll gelaufen der Speicherplatz der
Platz gleich und daher muss ich mich
ganz herzlich bedanken bei dieser Runde
ich bedanke mich für meinen Geist nicht
bedanke mich vor allem bei ihnen fürs
zuschauen wir sehen uns morgen wieder
bei 8:15 Uhr bis dann
[Musik]